[Música]
con nuestro primer invitado el día vamos
a analizar las implicaciones de la
visita a la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi
taiwán que desató todo tipo de
reacciones de rechazo por parte del
gobierno chino que recordemos sigue
reclamando la isla como parte de su
territorio lo vamos a analizar con bruno
vinti él es investigador doctoral en
relaciones internacionales en la london
school of economics especializado
también en relaciones sobre américa
latina eeuu y china
gracias por estar con nosotros esta
mañana de miércoles de bruno en directo
américa de france 24 hablemos por
supuesto de las implicaciones de esta
visita en el contexto en el que se da
ahí porque todavía es china entonces
sigue pues peleando por taiwán y hasta
dónde va a llevar estos chinas y
finalmente si taiwán en un futuro no
sabemos cuándo va a ser parte de la
china continental finalmente
gracias y esto poniendo un poco en
contexto histórico o es una situación
que viene desde la guerra civil de china
en los 40 cuando el partido comunista
chino toma el control sus opositores
nacionalistas escapan a taiwán y ahí
quedan bajo la protección de eeuu en los
70s eeuu reconoce finalmente a beijing
como el gobierno de china pero no
abandona a taiwán lo que sigue
protegiéndolo con relaciones
diplomáticas no oficiales pero taiwán
sigue contando con la protección en la
defensa de los eeuu y desde ese momento
sobre todo después de que taiwán se
convirtiera una democracia liberal el
estilo occidental las alianzas entre los
eeuu y taiwán se reforma diciendo dicho
ésto eeuu en todo este tiempo desde los
años setentas siempre se negó a
reconocer a taiwán como independiente
que eso claramente sería motivo de
guerra para china porque china sigue
considerando a taiwán parte de sus
territorios y jinping ha dicho que este
no es un problema que puede pasarse de
generación en generación
y debe ser resuelto cuanto antes
entonces la situación viene desde hace
muchas décadas lo que es particular del
viaje de pelosi es que se da en un
contexto
particularmente crítico para las
relaciones entre china y los eeuu y me
parece que es el contexto la visita en
sí como decían ustedes hace 25 años otro
presidente de la cámara de
representantes también visitó taiwán
pero en este tiempo china ya no es la
misma no es un país que aspira a
competir con los eeuu de igual a igual y
me parece que ese es el contexto clave
para entender porque esta visita está
generando tanto ruido en beijing claro y
precisamente hablemos de las reacciones
que ha tenido china a puede ser
rechazado contundentemente esta visita
de nancy pelosi a territorio taiwanés y
dice que va a tomar medidas que va a
tomar medidas digamos en represalia
contra la isla ya incluso puso sanciones
económicas a varios tipos de
importaciones pero que realmente pudiera
ser china como para decir
respeten mi posición política y no
quedar debilitada digamos a los ojos del
mundo tras la visita de pelosi
si justamente de ese sentido la reacción
de china cuando se filtró el viaje de
pelosi este un viaje que iba a suceder
en abril pero si lo uso porque porque
tuvo como bill y amistad fines de julio
se reveló que el viaje estaba de vuelta
en su agenda la reacción de china pues
tan furibunda que en ese sentido apeló
si casi no le quedó alternativa que
hacer el viaje porque lo contrario
hubiese resultado una especie de
capitulación ante ante china no hay que
también tener en cuenta el contexto
político en los eeuu
si hay algo de lo poco en lo que
coinciden demócratas y republicanos en
el congreso de eeuu es en la oposición
cada vez más fuerte a china
entonces pelos y en ese sentido el viaje
es actúa como representante de la enorme
mayoría de los congresistas
estadounidenses aunque para la casa
blanca como decías es una posición
incómoda china
está aumentando la presión el objetivo
es demostrar que lo que ellos consideran
provocaciones como estas va a tener
consecuencias para taiwán y sin dudas
los meses que siguen van a ser difíciles
en la zona va a haber ejercicios
militares de china muy cerca de aguas
que taiwán considera propias va a haber
posiblemente disparo de misiles muy
cerca de la isla de taiwán va a haber
aviones cazas chinos sobrevolando cada
vez más cerca de
taiwán entonces claramente si bien la
visita es un espaldarazo muy importante
para el gobierno de taiwán también es
cierto que va a tener consecuencias muy
difíciles y que en definitiva para
pelosi lo que fue un viaje de 24 horas
para taiwán van a ser consecuencias que
pueden durar mucho en el tiempo claro y
digamos vámonos adentro de eeuu como es
vista esta visita de pelosi a taiwán
realmente es apoyada por la mayoría de
los congresistas parece que el
presidente yo bailé no estaba como muy
de acuerdo con este viaje tampoco a más
que recordemos que tuvieron una llamada
bailén jingping hace 1 díaz a trabajo
unas semanas atrás entonces digamos como
queda en la política dentro de eeuu
totalmente para la casa blanca el timing
digamos de la visita no era el ideal
pero lo cierto es que pelosi lidera la
cámara de representantes en la tercera
figura más importante de la estructura
institucional de eeuu detrás del
presidente de la vicepresidenta también
es cierto que pelosi tiene 82 años y
este probablemente sean sus últimos
meses como presidenta de la cámara de
representantes y como las encuestas
anticipan los republicanos toman el
control entonces para pelos y como
señalaban también tiene una larga
historia de defensa de taiwán y de
protesta contra violaciones a los
derechos humanos en china era una
oportunidad para coronar su carrera
digamos con una visita histórica
a taiwán
como te decía incluso senadores
republicanos que no suelen coincidir con
la anci pelosi en absolutamente nada
respaldaron públicamente con una carta a
su visita son los republicanos
curiosamente los que los que más han
defendido esta visita de pelosi el
antecesor ya que hace 25 años visitó
taiwán era republicano en newbridge era
presidente de la cámara también
y hay también en el partido demócrata
creo gente que no quería incomodar a
bailén pero que respalda una posición de
fuerte apoyo a taiwán que sin llegar a
reconocer la independencia de taiwán que
todos consideran sería un paso demasiado
extremo quieren expresar sobre todo dado
el contexto de la guerra de ucrania
quieren expresar que eeuu es capaz de
defender a sus aliados más allá de la
oposición de países como rusia y china